hey the sparkle just whoa thing all
these sauces have gone right today we
are ranking the famous fast food sauces
like fast food I do I'm a big fast food
person I used to eat fast food a
paragraph yeah I mean I don't anymore
when I go to McDonald's I'd like to get
my fries in that old man is your
favorite yes sugar well oh all right
here we go
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes wait one put past them so the least
is Polynesian sauce I'm so sorry for the
name it just tasted like sweet and sour
sauce I can't say what the rash tastes
like some nice ranch and then we had a
zesty buffalo kick Turtles I like to
kick it like hit me but it's like let's
do love honey roasted barbecue that was
basically a chick-fil-a sauce which is
really weird move on to the next place
oh I appreciate how their packets are
all the same so similar to chick-fil-a
they've got their own barbecue sauce
they've got their own buffalo sauce they
got their own ranch sweet and sour they
will really mess with this certificate
err I'm watching this with the chicken
nuggets maple syrup like it maple syrup
that's gone off and Fleming all right
now let's have spicy buffalo already you
might need a water break yeah let's try
the hot mustard since want a spicy kick
and you know this was a sauce option so
that's definitely not even spicy it's
just mustard garsik often get barbecue
sauce let me call this my [ __ ] yes you
do
that's all of you tell me how goodness
it's already the same oh my mr. zing
yeah barbecue sauce at the top
undisputed king honey mustard
uh yeah number two number three we have
zesty yeah buffalo sauce ranch then this
hot mustard and then we don't want to
talk about this I'm setting fun
oh my want to start with the a blue oh
this isn't spicy at all but this is a
well seasoned sauce fryer I taste the
difference between the two of them
peppery let me pour this next one for
you
that's his energy oh that's a very sweet
thing for you to say of course I will
the last one we have is mono yeah yep
there you go there's patterns I think I
got a new appreciation for you enjoyed
you know what is it's straight company
is what makes it all better
Barbies I don't think I ever good
obviously let's start with the horsey
sauce
no it's no it's horseradish I don't hate
that let's put it army sauce ketchup soy
sauce no it's good yeah Padma she meet
up with the mozzarella snake right yeah
this might be honey mustard might not be
we'll see oh why don't you fake bones
bad lardo it tastes like beef broth that
like beef stock with some honey mustard
why do I spend my Friday morning yeah
well technically I have breakfast with a
beautiful woman Arby's sauce that horthy
softened I have a great time with these
ones alright Popeye I'm a gambler with
any of you sauces to go through all
right through it from the end there on
your end that ranch taste off to me are
you sure you're okay did you gargle
gargle and try not to spark okay this
one looks like fun I think I might like
this one this is actually very good I'm
gonna put this at number 100
that's a oily looking sauce yeah well
let's mix it first
Oh Oh No
[Laughter]
Mardi Gras mustard oh that's very seats
indeed how we talking about that I mean
it's I like it better these two yeah
just put it above that one it's decent
oh sweet seat sauce you're gonna hate
this I can tell
yep I told you oh it's like sweet and
sour sauce this is the bold barbecue sir
I do like barbecue sauce so go black and
ranch sauce okay scoop the other ranch
yeah this has a smoky taste to it Oh old
Vicki sauce I'm black and ranch Mardi
Gras mustard sauce and then these three
which whereby you buffalo sauce sweet
heat ranch and buttermilk ranch sauce
Deb solid I do love the some ranch city
ranch honey mustard baby don't honey
mustard little sweet for my taste earn
credit for hot taco sauce for tacos you
know I'm talk to us so we have fries
yeah basic sweet and sour sauce a little
worried about this one you know we don't
like that I need my Sparkle sauce
barbecue sauce red hot sauce buttermilk
ranch I'm surprised by how high we put
it by didn't minded this one honey
mustard sweet-and-sour sauce and then
hot taco sauce and the cages Popeyes if
you had to pick one sauce out of all the
sauces we had today let's say you had a
man over and he'll added himself up in
one of these sauces oh whoa